I have never felt closer to mom I'm in
the exact same place that she was all
those years ago you're pregnant yeah
yeah
tonight it's a night for celebration
come on let's get this show on the road
I was told you couldn't come I miss
Ponte Gnaeus person no you're not no I'm
not
[Music]
it takes three great men to create such
a woman we never did ask you guys what
happened when you met my mother I don't
know what my future holds but the world
is wide I wanna make some memories
there's an island cala Carrie people
used to think if you sailed on from
there you'd fall off the edge of the
world
sounds like the place for me I'm beau
I'm Donna is literally the handsomest
man in the world
sucker this guy's incredible I think we
should stay here together may the rest
of our lives be the best of our lives
just tell me you didn't invite your
grandmother Wicked Witch of the West
[Music]
I've decided to commit to being a
grandmother grandma you weren't invited
that's the best kind of party little
girl
[Music]
my soulmate may actually be calmed the
line must be wine all three of us are
grandfathers that's that
[Music]
look what you've done with the place she
wanted to make a mum proud if she hasn't
done that all her life
[Music]
we can't tell anybody about the baby yet
I just told bill yeah and I told Harry I
told many many people got about to
become a great girl mother
great-grandmother I'm living that out of
the bio
[Music]
you